that powerful winter storm we've been  warning you about is moving through  parts of the country the National  Weather Service calling it a once in a  generation storm producing blizzard  conditions from the central to Eastern  United States millions are in its path  well this comes as about 3 million  people are booked on about 47 000  scheduled flights today making it one of  the busiest travel days of the year now  this is video from Denver International  Airport in Colorado this morning  hundreds of flights have been canceled  there as conditions worsen and let's  take a look now heading east this is in  Chicago the snow is gorgeous there it's  really coming down it's a beautiful  outdoor area according to O'Hare  International Airport's Twitter nearly  540 flights have been canceled at that  location today